wir haben diesen elmar zirkus gehabt ich
glaube zum zweiten mal bereits und im
desaster von dem fernsehen schaute hin
und dachte das ist ja wie früher im
kommunismus die leute treffen sind alle
einer meinung und wie üblich bei solchen
veranstaltungen wird das schluss
communication am anfang verfasst und
zwar nicht von den teilnehmern sondern
von sogenannten sherpas den leuten zu
arbeiten dieses spektakel hat 166
millionen euro gekostet was eine
unglaubliche summe ist aber für andere
ist es peanuts wenn wir den chinesen 450
millionen euro entwicklungshilfe
schicken sondern sind 160 millionen euro
wirklich nicht so viel das waren 18.000
polizisten unterwegs die leute in der
gegend haben sich beklagt weil das ganze
leben zum stillstand gekommen ich finde
so ein g 7 ist schon das wichtigen ich
bin auch der meinung g7 muss einfach
sein bin ich total ihrer meinung einfach
mal ein bisschen auch wenn so die bitte
von johnson sind aber irgendwie paar
muskeln muss man schon mal ca
[Musik]